I'll just the whole time
[Laughter]
[Music]
episode of scored stories today we got
Tim
wow wow hey
[Applause]
what's up everybody what up Tim how you
guys feeling today good wonderful I have
a beautiful story to tell you today oh
please do I've told the story a few
times on different podcasts and things
but
today we're going to do it with a
keyboard yeah never like this
so I know uh we've all been 21.
excited for life
you got so many things that you've never
experienced before you just want to live
life
so one time me and the homies
all 21. that's dangerous fresh
Young
broke
we decided
we gonna go to Las Vegas oh yeah I lived
there so
you know we uh we didn't have a whole
lot of money but we got a sweet ass room
at the luxurious
Luxor
[Music]
it was a special deal
oh special deal
because look we got a room with a hot
tub in it oh
for all the dudes for all the dudes it
was four of us me Ricky Shucks PD flow
superego my homies and we thought
we gonna get some [__] this weekend
so the whole weekend we're just trying
to
game up different girls trying to get
numbers trying to get some ass right to
no avail no luck everything was a fail
and then one time we were at the pool
talking to these girls
still a fail
the last night
[Music]
and imma get a girl to the room tonight
now mind you we're very broke I'm
talking about eating McDonald's every
day double cheeseburgers wow
[Laughter]
make chickens the spicy McChickens too
but for a dollar we had no money but
tonight I was like imma get some ass
imma get it to the hotel room and I'ma
smash something in Vegas because we were
feeling ourselves you know what I'm
saying I was young I was stupid I didn't
know how to dress
I went to Vegas with uh some polka dot
Vans matching polka dot tie some [__]
plastic sunglasses with the white
outside thinking I was flat first
movement yes
[Music]
yeah like a G6
but it wasn't working anyways last night
we're horny I'm walking around the
casino trying to find a girl to talk to
wow I see the sexy ass asian girl at the
slots by herself by herself
I'm like you know what
I'm gonna talk to this girl so I see her
I'm by myself I'm like looking I'm like
what am I gonna say what am I gonna say
what am I gonna say I get it together
I'm in my head I walk up to her real
smooth real smooth I'm like hey
you uh winning anything tonight
[Laughter]
it's like it's all right
I'm like okay well look man um if you're
bored you got nothing to do tonight got
a little hotel suite we gotta like we
got alcohol let me know if you want to
come through she's just kind of like
playing her slots she's like
okay yeah I can do that like oh sick I'm
like okay cool she's like okay cool let
me get your number she gets my number
cool she's like all right I'll text you
I'll call you like all right cool
I go back to the room the homies are
chilling I'm like guess what I got a
girl coming to the room
they're like no
yeah yeah jump I capture the flag
they're like yo no way I'm like yes this
girl's coming to the room but then I'm
waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting I'm
cleaning up I'm cleaning up thinking
she's gonna come through it's [__]
hour and a half goes by she doesn't come
through yet I'm like [__] is she gonna
come through the homies are like nah
she's not going through then I get a
call yes
I'm like yeah um what's up she's like
okay you still want to come by I'm like
yeah of course girl she's like of course
stupid of course you idiot
she's like are you gonna take care of me
I'm like confused but I'm like girl you
know I'm gonna take care of you of
course so I'm like oh yeah I got you we
hang up so I tell the homies I'm like yo
she's coming through but she said am I
gonna take care of her that's kind of
weird everyone's like hmm then I
realized oh [__]
is she a prostitute oh
she might be a prostitute
but I'm like [__] it we'll see what
happens
I tell her to come through she's like
meet me downstairs at the elevator I go
downstairs two guys walk her to me oh
she she comes with me I'm thinking oh
maybe it's older maybe the brothers the
homies whatever uncles uncles so cool we
get in the elevator she comes to the
room with the two dudes no no no it's
just her the dudes walking the elevator
it's just me and her we're talking
making small talk come into the room
mind you it's one room with with three
guys with three guys two beds in a hot
tub we come into the room for some
reason my friends did not leave the room
why because they're stupid
they're in the hot tub my boy superego
they're in the hot tub my boy Superior
goes in the hot tub with bubbles on his
face like a beard what they're all
chilling in the hot tub get out of there
so I'm like hey girl I'm like you want
me to make you a drink or something like
that she's like okay
she comes to the little area where we
have our drinks I make her a little
[__] Smirnoff vodka and whatever the
fly roller yeah uh I'm balling right so
I pour her drink we're sipping and I'm
like
can I ask you a question she's like
what's up I'm like hey are you here
cause you like want to hang out or are
you looking to get compensated
she's like um
first of all
look I'm an Entertainer I'm like um I
like those words
so in my head I'm like okay well let me
see what's um how much she's she doesn't
let me stop you right there we first of
all we don't talk like that oh so what
what are we what are we doing she's like
well
let me ask you this how much do you have
I'm like whoa all right I'm like well
check me out check me out check me out I
we got this hotel suite with the hot tub
we bought all these bottles of Smirnoff
so [__] nothing
[Laughter]
so she's like
okay okay
well it was nice meeting you oh I'm like
cool cool I'm like here I'll walk you
out we walk past all the homies in the
hot tub
I walk her to the door uh and I I close
the door but then I'm still gonna walk
around but I lean back to the homies I'm
like yo
so as I'm walking around
[__] Rick
mind you we're 21. Rick is very excited
that I was just with a prostitute
so as I'm walking her down the hallway
Rick opens the door he's like yo
prostitutes are the [__]
oh [__] why I don't know we were young
We Were Young we were 21. we never dealt
with processes before and I mean now we
love process I'm just kidding so so
she's like well that was mature of him
I walked into the elevator
said bye she's like hey thanks you
didn't have to walk me that was nice of
you I'm like it's cool man hey do your
thing go back to the room but gentleman
I'm a gentleman go back to the room
and uh you guys all jacked off we all
jacked each other off
and that was that was the end good night
[Laughter]
and that's the story
can we scrounge up some money and maybe
we could share we literally had no money
we were literally eating double
cheeseburgers all weekend why did they
stay in the room with only one girl this
is just young young man [__] I I even
like in the moment I wasn't like what
the [__] y'all still doing here yeah I
was just all right guys what's up I'm
gonna go talk to her and over here now
and then
freak out that she came into a room full
of three four Dudes I don't know what's
she thinking I'm gonna make four times
the month probably it's Vegas you know
oh but here's the thing get back on the
keyboards here's a click here's the
kicker oh [__] [__] years the Marvel
yeah years [__] later years later
some guy I forget how Rick was talking
to him but like Rick was like hey no
this guy's like hey you know what's
funny is um
your boy Tim
tried you know he took one of my girls
to his room
so the [__] pimp was talking to Rick
years later about some other [__] was
like yeah you know yeah Tim he this
[__] recognized me at the at the
elevator and didn't say [__]
he was a fan he should have gave you a
free deal what the heck
you want a youtubing already back then
yeah yeah and he recognized you to do
nothing yeah what a shitty pimp yeah
what the heck you could have got a
sponsorship I guess I could have got a
free a free over the pants handy at
least
over the pan I'm still hype on [__]
Rick I'm not going prostitutes other
[__] yeah man we were babies real mature
that's a [__] t-shirt
curious what would have happened
if she's like
yeah I'm here to entertain
and um all four of you guys oh God just
had our digs out yeah but that's the
night I learned that if you see a girl
just hanging out by herself at the slot
machines like 2 A.M she's probably a
prostitute in Vegas oh yeah I like how
she controlled it though she was like we
don't talk like that yeah she's like
hold on no uh that's you're gonna
legally we can't say that but
interesting oh at my Vegas prostitutes
you don't say how much okay you don't
say this is a transaction you say how
much you have and we'll see where we go
from there from zero to ten what was she
was she like a 10 well she's like she
was pretty bro she's like uh I was like
an eight wow very like you know I like
all types of different women but she was
a slender pretty Asian girl in like a
dress like a Sasha Singleton
Singleton or more of a oh that's the
great one yeah I don't know who that is
but um let's see in terms of like import
models it's physically like Elizabeth
Tran I would say
she's an import chick she's like a Jerry
Lee she just got married but shout out
to her congrats on the marriage but
visibly that's how as we're using her as
a scale hey congratulations for a
prostitute he met at 21. is she like a
Magic Cube I don't know either she was
in a mission impossible three Maggie Q
like a Michelle you know they're like
Maggie she's like a child
damn that's a crazy ass story though
that's tight yeah yeah nice like I mean
now I could totally afford a bras too
but yeah yeah that's what's up yeah I go
for you man that's tight I never got one
in America
I was like it's not how much I have how
many homies do you have
you better bring it yeah other chicks
another question you never you never was
said do you have any friends that would
like to come hang out and party with us
for my friends at this point I knew I
couldn't even afford one so I was like
what was the point no before you knew
she was a hooker oh you're just like
just hey let's do you have friends come
Park I'll be according to the store he
knew she was a hooker the whole time uh
no he didn't know till later back then
it was like I was so focused on just
trying to get some ass before we left
Vegas and I was like and you're thinking
only buyers
yeah bro
[Laughter]
bro code was when you pick up a girl and
you have [__] lonely ass friends you
say do you have any friends I wasn't
trying to push my luck dog but also yeah
when you're 21 you can't wait to go
around the corner go oh yeah
that's true that's true yeah I was just
praying that she was gonna [__] use
my number and text me you know that's
funny especially if she was hot that's
why it's not easy to get a date these
days these days you just get a hooker I
remember one time we're in Vegas you
know Rick Rick had a shirt on they said
I love hot moms
we're going down the escalator this
older white chick was like I'm
and we were like yeah
yeah you learned a lot of [__] you know
he could have got some hot mom he could
have yeah she could have that day
especially yeah I never got laid in
Vegas
only the girls that I brought there yeah
oh yeah no actually I did oh my God I
did that's all right next one next up
hit the keys end credits
oh my God
[Music]